whenever big Tech CEOs get questioned by
Congress it typically does not go well
for either side why if you had nothing
to hide would you need to downplay the
association with bite dance in China
congresswoman I have not seen this demo
why should we trust Facebook your user
agreement sucks I'm going to suggest to
you that you go back home and rewrite it
and tell your 1200 an hour lawyers no
disrespect they're good but but tell
them you want it written in English in
non-swahili so the average American can
understand that would be a start
Microsoft's actions have stifled
competition in the operating system and
browser markets but most importantly it
has restricted the choices available for
consumers in America and around the
world
CEOs get grilled the Congress members
end up looking like complete out of
touch idiots and the company in question
usually ends up getting regulated the
justice department has charged Microsoft
with engaging in anti-competitive and
exclusionary practices designed to
maintain its Monopoly in personal
computer operating systems but this time
things are different because unlike
Zuckerberg or The Tick Tock CEO Sam
Altman the CEO of openai played at
smarts instead of arguing with Congress
instead of saying that no we do not need
to regulate AI Sam Altman completely
agree with everything Congress had to
say and he had them eating out of the
palm of his hand open AI was founded on
the belief that artificial intelligence
has the potential to improve nearly
every aspect of our lives but also that
it creates serious risks we have to work
together to manage I think jobs and
employment and what we're all going to
do with our time really matters I agree
that when we get to very powerful
systems the landscape will change I
think I'm just more optimistic that we
are incredibly creative and we find new
things to do with better and that will
keep happening my worst fears are that
we cause significant we the field the
technology the industry cause
significant harm to the world I think
that could happen in a lot of different
ways it's why we started the company
it's big part of why I'm here today and
why we've been here in the past and
we've been able to spend some time with
you I think if this technology goes
wrong it can go quite wrong and we want
to be vocal about that we want to work
with the government to prevent that from
happening but we we try to be very
clear-eyed about what the downside cases
and the work that we have to do to
mitigate that Congress says AI needs
more regulation Sam Altman agrees we
need to find ways to license and control
new AI startups that's 100 right Sam
Altman completely voted on every single
little concern Congress had about AI Sam
Altman said AI needs regulation and what
do you know I have the perfect little
plan on how Congress can do that and
Congress loved it Sam claimed the U.S
should create a separate agency to
oversee AI I guess is in the chimoff
camp he wants the agency to issue
licenses to train and use AI models a
little regulatory capture there as we
say in the biz he also claims and this
was interesting dovetailing with elon's
CNBC interview with I think Dave Farber
which is very good that he owns no
equity in open AI whatsoever and was
quote doing it because he loves it while
Sam Altman sounds so Noble so
self-sacrificing he really is putting
the interest of the public before his
own but come on you and I know
differently they corporations tend to
like regulation because think about it
as a big Corporation you can afford the
lawyer's lobbyists and money that it
takes to comply with regulations but
your competitors can't the aspiring mini
Sam Altman over there trying to start
the next open AI from his garage Camp so
if AI regulations are coming and indeed
they are why fight them why make
yourself an enemy to Congress instead
the smarter decision is to just bow down
nod your head yes and generously offer
your helping hand in writing these
regulations yes you are right
Congressman we do need regulation and if
you need help I am but your humble
servants after all the game of Monopoly
is real easy to win when you're the one
that helped write the rules
one company that is also following in
Sam Owen's footsteps and taking
advantage of these upcoming AI
regulations is a company you need to
know about called Edge total
intelligence or HTI see every company
out there needs some kind of AI
component to compete these days that's
why every app you use has been adding
generative AI features recently but
generative AI also poses a lot of risk
to businesses bias copyright conflicts
spewing out the wrong information cyber
crime fraud on top of that with these
coming regulations every single company
out there is going to need help
navigating these wrestling regulations
or in other words there's a lot of money
to be made and that is where HTI comes
in HTI started in the defense and
intelligence sector and now specializes
in helping the world's largest companies
navigate this mess so they can work
within laws and regulations using their
super powerful B2B software called
edgecore which is why there's probably
going to be a lot more demand for STI in
the future as the regulations come so
more about HDI later but they've been a
private company for most of their
existence and they just went public in
2022 some of their clients include JP
Morgan and Motorola CB insights says
they're basically a more affordable
version of palantir they've got a 950
million dollar contract with jadc2 the
military's push to connect all the
military branches together with AI and
if you're interested in learning more
you should definitely check them out
with the link below they're the paid
sponsor of this video and we're really
glad to have them so pause the video
scroll down and click the link below now
back to the video
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the 90s and Microsoft was on a roll
I can't believe it you did it we did it
it looks great this is a miracle this is
Microsoft Excel but Bill Gates was
making a critical mistake Microsoft in
the early 1990s was the largest company
in the world incredibly successful and
they spent exactly zero dollars on
lobbying on cronyism on lawyers they had
no presence in Washington DC and so Bill
Gates got subpoenaed in front of
Congress and they were literally brought
in front of Congress they were yelled at
by a republican Owen hatch from Utah he
said you guys need to get involved here
in Washington DC you need to build a
building here you need to hire a lawyer
in other words the unspoken text you
need to bribe me and Microsoft walked
out of the meeting and said you know
what you leave us alone we will leave
you alone we're busy we're running the
biggest company in the world there's a
lot to do big mistake the justice
department has charged Microsoft six
months later knock on the door at
Microsoft we're from the justice
department and we're here to prosecute
you because you are offering the
American public you're offering your
customers a product for free this is
Internet Explorer at a time when we were
buying Netscape and paying money for it
they offered it for free and that was
deemed you know bad business practices
trying to dominate the market for 10
years there to fight that lawsuit they
lost they got regulated they got
controlled guess how much Microsoft
spent today in Washington DC how much
tens of millions of dollars they have a
beautiful building about equal distance
from the White House and from there for
congress they have lawyers they have
lobbyists they spend a lot of money and
indeed a lot of the other tech companies
like Google learned the lesson the
Microsoft case made it abundantly clear
to All Tech companies once you get big
enough you better learn to kiss the ring
and it's a lesson the Same album of open
AI has taken to hearts
I
[Music]
EU has been working towards passing this
AI good here we go there are a couple of
weeks ahead of these conversations in
the U.S but I mean as you read through
this AI Act and the proposal that it's
uh that it's put forth it almost becomes
the kind of thing that you say I just
don't know if these folks really
understand how the technology works
because it's almost as if they're going
to audit and have you know an assessment
of the risk level of every software
application out there and that the
tooling and the necessary infrastructure
to be able to do that just makes no
sense in the context of Open Source
software in the context of an open
internet in the context of how quickly
software and applications and tools
evolve and you make tweets to an
algorithm and you got to resubmit it for
authorization here's the thing about
regulating AI right now there is no
realistic or effective way to do it
we're talking about people who can't
even regulate something as simple as
Tick Tock or Facebook trying to police
something that is developing faster than
anything else out there right now and
Sam Altman knows this but he's still
pushing for regulation even though he
knows completely impractical according
to him Congo should create an
independent agency that audits tracks
and gives licenses the companies that
want to train and develop AI models chat
GPT style models if unregulated could
increase online misinformation bolster
cyber criminals even threaten confidence
in election systems so he basically
bought into the center's narrative and
like you said agreed to create a new
agency that would license models and can
take licenses away he said that he would
create safety standards specific tests
that a mall has to pass before it can be
deployed he says he would require
independent audits who can say the model
is or isn't in compliance but anyone
with a basic understanding of how AI
development Works knows that this is
nothing more than a Fool's errand then
it becomes very hard for a regulatory
agency to go in and audit every server
or every computer or every computer on a
network and say what model are you
running is that an approved model is
that not an approved model it's almost
like having a regulatory agency that has
to go in and audit and assess us whether
a Linux upgrade or some sort of you know
open source platform that's being run on
some server is appropriately vetted and
checked and so it's almost like a Fool's
errand and so if I'm running one of
these companies and I'm trying to you
know get Congress off my and get all
these Regulators off my I'm going to say
go ahead and regulate us because the
truth is there really isn't a great or
easy path or ability to do that and
there certainly won't be in five or ten
years this is going to be a near
impossible task to try and track and
approve llms and audit servers that are
running llms and audit apps and audit
what's behind the tools that everyday
people are using and I wish everyone the
best of luck in trying to do so but
that's kind of the joke of the whole
thing is like let's go ahead and paddle
these Congress people on the shoulder
and say you got it you're right if you
create an agency where people have to go
get their permission it's a licensing
scheme you're gonna be waiting in some
line of Untold lengths it won't be like
a physical line at the DMV building it's
gonna be a virtual line where you're in
some queue where there's probably going
to be some overwork regulator who does
doesn't even know how they're supposed
to approve your project they're just
going to be trying to cover their Ops
because if the project ends up being
something nefarious then they get blamed
for it so that's what's gonna end up
happening Sam Altman knows all this he
knows that none of this is feasible and
that's exactly the points
just days before Sam Altman's hearing he
was actually invited to a dinner of
around 60 Congress members where he got
the show off just how advanced chat gbt
had become Sam got to do a little song
and dance a little live demo of all the
fun cool interesting things Chachi BT
could do just a few days before those
same Congress members are supposed to
grill him on whether or not AI is
controllable well it seems very very bad
that ahead of a hearing meant to inform
how the sector gets regulated the CEO of
one of the corporations that would be
subject to that regulation gets to
present a magic show to The Regulators
End quotes one Professor from the
University of Washington sudden all of
these different Senators had different
theories of harm that they were
promoting and they were all basically
hammers looking for a nail you know they
all wanted to regulate this thing and
they didn't really pay much of any
attention to the ways that existing laws
could already be you boost absolutely to
stop any of these things if you commit a
crime with AI there are plenty of
criminal laws every single thing they
talked about could be handled through
existing law if the amount to being
harmed at all yeah but they want to jump
right to creating a new agency and new
regulations and Sam I think did the you
know expedient thing here which is
basically buy into it in order
if this was a chess game Sam got to the
mid game he traded all the pieces and
went right to the end game let's just
try to Checkmate here I've got the lead
I got the 10 billion from Microsoft
everybody else get a license and try to
catch up Friedberg Sam was able to grow
open AI to the top because there was no
regulation because there was no red tape
but now if an aspiring mini Sam Altman
wants to follow in his footsteps too bad
they're gonna need lawyers lobbyists and
millions of dollars before they can even
write a single line of code I think you
know Sam just went straight for the end
game here which is regulatory capture
normally when a tech executive goes and
testifies at these hearings they're in
the hot seat and they get grilled and
that didn't happen here because you know
Sam almond basically bought Into The
Narrative of these Senators do you guys
think that this was Sam's way of pulling
up the ladder behind him of course 100
just like absolutely it is and it's
because no you can you can prove it he
made open AI closed AI by making it not
open source but there's another reason
why Sam might want to let the government
get their grubby fingers on AI if you're
Sam you're smart enough to know how
quickly the models are commoditizing and
how many different models there are that
you know can provide provide similar
degrees of functionality as you just
pointed out jcal so I don't think it's
about trying to lock in your model I
think it's about recognizing the
impracticality of creating some
regulatory regime around model auditing
and so you're very so that in that world
in that scenario where you have that
Vision you have that foresight do you go
to Congress and tell them that they're
dumb to regulate AI or do you go to
Congress and you say great you should
regulate AI knowing that it's like hey
yeah you should go ahead and stop the
Sun from shining you know like it's just
yeah so basically he's telling him to do
that because he knows they can't no
therefore he gets all the points all the
joy points all the social credit I don't
say virtual signaling but he gets all
the credit relationship credit with
Washington for saying what they want to
hear reflecting back to them whatever
the real reason may be Sam Altman has
Congress right where he wants them in
the hearing one Senator even joked and
asked quote whether almond might
consider heading up a hypothetical
Federal agency charged with regulating
the AI industry End quotes
Sam humbly declined saying that he loves
his job but he didn't hesitate to offer
to send the senator a list of potential
candidates for the job wow how
convenient but aside from all this
criticism of Sam Altman there is
legitimately a case for AI regulation
it's just not the kind of Regulation
Congress has in mind
[Music]
I think Buffett is right two weeks ago
he equated AI to nuclear weapons which
is an incredibly powerful technology
whose Genie you can't put back in the
bottle who's 99.9 of use cases are
generally quite societally positive but
the 0.1 percent of use cases destroys
Humanity artificial general intelligence
or AGI an AI that is actually sentient
and smarter than humans is a true
threats but can you be more precise
about what's potentially dangerous and
scary like what could it do what
specifically are you worried about going
with old sayings the penis Mighty of the
sword so if you have a super intelligent
AI that is capable of writing incredibly
well in a way that is very influential
you know convincing and then and it's
constantly figuring out what is more
convincing to people over time and then
enter social media for example Twitter
but also Facebook and others you know
and and potentially manipulates public
opinion in a way that is very bad how
would we even know and a lot of big tech
companies like open Ai and Google are
actively trying to create AGI it's even
an open as company charter as their main
goal but nowhere in the four hours of
Sam Alban's hearing did anyone even
mention the dangers of AGI and if AGI is
going to become a thing do we want it
completely controlled by open AI or
Google or even elon's upcoming AI
company probably not and yet Congress is
so inept and out of touch that they
didn't even think about discussing this
so while Sam Altman gets the AI
regulation he wants regulations that
will crush his competitors open Ai and
Google would be able to create AGI free
from the prying eyes of Washington
Congress is getting duped humanity is
getting duped and we're all falling for
it
please
foreign
no matter what your thoughts in AI
regulation are they are coming and the
real winners from all of this are gonna
be the people like Sam Altman who find a
unique way to turn these regulations
into the opportunity of a lifetime and
aside from open AI another company that
is doing this that you need to know
about is called Edge total intelligence
or STI HTI helps companies like JPMorgan
navigate all the potential risks and
regulations when it comes to Ai and they
deal with their B2B software called Edge
core think of it like a more affordable
version of palantir according to CB
insights some of their other clients
include Accenture telephonica one of the
largest telecommunications companies in
the world and ADP the Giant payroll and
HR company so as you can see these are
all literally some of the biggest
companies in the world while also
working with defense and intelligence
clients like the dod U.S Navy NATO and
the department of energy like their 950
million dollar contract with jadc2 the
military's push to connect all the
military branches together with AI and
if these are just some of hti's giant
clients today think about all the other
giant Clans they're probably going to
get in the future with the Russian Ai
and AI regulation are headed in see most
people only know about consumer tech
companies like Netflix and stuff but
what people forget is that there are a
ton of B2B tech companies that provide
the tools to help make the Netflix's of
the world possible and most people have
never even heard of their names and STI
is one of them and when you have a JP
Morgan as a client you can bet that
they're paying a lot more money than the
average Netflix user STI has been a
private company for most of their life
but they just went public in 2022 and if
you want to learn more about them scroll
down and click the link below right now
videos like this wouldn't be possible
without paid sponsors like HTI so scroll
down and click the link below now
thank you foreign
[Music]